I remember being very fearful of the unknown of what might happen next.
I remember it being like a bad dream.
I remember the plane flying over my head.
I remember kind of hiding my eyes and not looking at the television.
I remember the faces of my colleagues as the building sways so violently...
....after the plane crashed.
I remember fliers of all the missing people.
That is an image that seared in my mind.
I remember seeing people helping one another.
I think it's pulled the community together.
I remember people talking to each other.
...an unbelievable sense of community.
I remember all of us coming together.
It wasn't just a New York thing.
We all were affected in some way.
You just wanna do something.
I will remember by planting a tree.
I will continue to serve as a volunteer firefighter.
I will remember by taking my daughter to the Bronx Zoo.
I will call my grandmother.
I will clean up my room.
I will...
I will make a difference.